let me ask you about AI it seems like
this year for the entirety of the human
civilization is an interesting year for
the development of artificial
intelligence
a lot of interesting stuff is happening
So Meta is a big part of that uh meta's
developed llama which is a 65 billion
parameter model
uh there's a lot of interesting
questions they can ask here one of which
has to do with open source but first can
you tell the story of developing of this
model and uh making the complicated
decision of how to release it yeah sure
I think you're right first of all that
in the last year there have been a bunch
of advances on scaling up these large
Transformer models so there's the
language equivalent of it with large
language models uh the sort of the image
generation equivalent with these large
diffusion models
um there's a lot of fundamental research
that's gone into this and
meta has taken the approach
of being quite open and academic in in
our development
um of AI part of this is we want to have
the best people in the world researching
this and
um and a lot of the best people want to
know that they're going to be able to
share their work so that's part of the
deal that we that we have is that you
know we can get you know if if you're
one of the top AI researchers in the
world you can come here you can get
access to kind of industry scale
um infrastructure and and and part of
our ethos is that we we want to share
what's what's invented
um broadly we do that with a lot of the
the different AI tools that we create
and llama is the language model that
that our research team made and
you know we we did in a limited
um a limited open source release for it
right where which was intended for
researchers to be able to use it
um
but you know the responsibility and
getting safety right on these is um is
very important so we didn't think that
for the first one there were a bunch of
questions around whether we should be
releasing this commercially so we kind
of punted on that for for V1 of of llama
and just released it from research now
obviously by releasing it for research
um you know it's out there but but
companies know that that they're that
they're not supposed to kind of put it
into commercial releases and um you know
we're working on the follow-up models
for this and and thinking through how
um what what the the how exactly this
should work for for follow-on now that
we've had time to to work on a lot more
of the the safety and
um and the pieces around that but but
overall I mean this is
I just kind of think that
that it would be good
if
there were a lot of different folks who
had the ability to build state of the
art technology here you know it's in not
just a small number of of big companies
we're to train one of these AI models
the state-of-the-art models is
um you know just takes you know hundreds
of millions of dollars of infrastructure
right so there are not that many
organizations in the world
um that can do that at the biggest scale
today and no it gets it gets more
efficient every day so
um so I I do think that that will be
available to more Focus over time but
but I just think like there's there's
all this Innovation out there that
people can create and um
and and I I just think that will will
also learn a lot by by seeing what the
whole community of students and
um and hackers and startups and
different folks
um build with this and that's kind of
that's kind of been how we've approached
this and it's also we've done a lot of
our infrastructure and we took our whole
data center design and our server design
and we we built this open compute
project where we just made that public
and
um part of the theory was like all right
if we make it set more people can use
this server design then um then that'll
enable more Innovation it'll also make
the server design more efficient and
that'll that'll make our business more
efficient too so that's worked and we've
we've just done this with a lot of our
our infrastructure
so for people who don't know you did the
limited release I think in February of
one of this year of llama
and it got quote unquote leaked
meaning like it's uh
escaped
the uh the the limited release aspect
but it was
you know that something you probably
anticipated given that it's just to
release the reasons we shared it with
researchers right so it's just trying to
make sure that there's like a slow
release yeah uh but from there I just
would love to get your comment on what
happened next which is like this is a
very vibrant open source community that
just builds stuff on top of it there's
uh llama CPP that basically stuff that
makes it more efficient to run on
smaller computers uh there's combining
with uh reinforcement learning with
human feedback so some of the different
interesting fine-tuning mechanisms
there's then also like fine-tuning and a
GPT three generations there's a lot of
uh GPT for all alpaca uh colossal AI all
these kinds of models just kind of
spring up like
run on top of wood yeah like what do you
think about that no I think it's been
really neat to see I mean there's been
folks who are getting it to run on local
devices right so if you're an individual
who just you know wants to experiment
you know with this at home
you probably don't have a large budget
to get access to like a large amount of
cloud compute so getting it to run on
your local laptop
um you know is is uh is pretty good
right and pretty relevant
um and then there are things like yeah
llama CPP
um re-implemented it more efficiently so
you know now even when we run our own
versions of it we can do it on way less
compute and it just way more efficient
save a lot of money
um for everyone who uses this so that
that is is good
um
I do think it's worth calling out that
because this was a relatively early
release
um
llama isn't quite as on the frontier as
for example the biggest open AI models
or the biggest Google models right when
you mentioned that the largest llama
model that we released had 65 billion
parameters and no one knows you know I
guess outside of open AI exactly what
the specs are for um for for gpd4 but
but I I think the you know my
understanding is it's like 10 times
bigger and I think Google's Palm model
is is also I think has about 10 times as
many parameters now the Llama models are
very efficient so they perform well for
for something that's around 65 billion
parameters so for me that was also part
of this because there's this whole
debate around you know is it good for
everyone in the world to have access to
um to the most Frontier AI models and I
I think as the AI models start
approaching something that's like a
super human intelligence events like
that's a bigger question that we'll have
to Grapple with but right now I mean
these are still you know very basic
tools they're um you know they're
they're powerful in the sense that you
know a lot of Open Source software like
databases or web servers can enable a
lot of pretty important things
um but
I don't think anyone looks at the the
you know the current generation of llama
and thinks it's um you know anywhere
near a super intelligence so I think
that a bunch of those questions around
like is it is it good to to kind of get
out there I think at this stage surely
you you want more researchers working on
it for all the reasons that
um that open source software has a lot
of advantages and we talked about
efficiency before but another one is
just open source software tends to be
more secure because you have more people
looking at it openly and scrutinizing it
and finding holes in it and that makes
it more safe so I think at this point
it's more
I think it's generally agreed upon that
open source software is generally more
secure and safer than things that are
kind of developed in a silo where people
try to get through security through
obscurity so I think that for the scale
of of what we're seeing now with AI
I think we're more likely to get to you
know good alignment and good
um understanding of of kind of what
needs to do to make this work well by
having it be open source and and that's
something that I think is is quite good
to have out there and and happening
publicly at this point meta released a
lot of models as open source so uh the
massively multi-lingual speech model
I'll ask you questions about this but
the point is
uh you've open source quite a lot you've
been spearheading the open source
movement where's uh that's really
positive inspiring to see from one angle
from the research angle of course
there's folks who are really terrified
about the existential threat of
artificial intelligence and those folks
will say that you know
um you have to be careful about the open
sourcing uh step but where do you see
the future of Open Source here uh as
part of meta the tension here is do you
want to release the magic sauce that's
one
tension and the other one is uh do you
want to put a powerful tool in the hands
of uh Bad actors even though it probably
has a huge amount of positive impact
also
yeah I mean again
a stage that we're at in the development
of AI I don't think anyone looks at the
current state of things and thinks that
this is super intelligence
um and you know the models that we're
talking about for the Llama models here
are you know generally an order of
magnitude smaller than what open AI or
Google are doing so
I think that at least for the stage that
we're in now the equities
balance strongly in my view towards
doing this more openly
um I think if you got something that was
closer to Super intelligence then I
think you'd have to discuss that more
and and think through that
um a lot more and we haven't made a
decision yet as to what we would do if
we were in that position but I don't
think I think there's a good chance that
we're pretty far off from that position
so
um so
I'm not
uh I'm certainly not saying that the
position that we're taking on this now
applies to every single thing that we
would ever do and you know certainly
inside the company you know we probably
do more open source work than you know
most of the other big tech companies but
we also don't open source everything and
a lot of our the core kind of app code
for WhatsApp or Instagram or something I
mean we're not open sourcing that it's
not like a a general enough piece of
software that would be useful for a lot
of people to do different things
um you know whereas
the software that we do whether it's
like an open source server design or
um or basically you know things like
memcache right like a good you know it
was probably our earliest project
um that I worked on it was probably one
of the last things that I that I coded
and and led directly for the company
um but but basically this like caching
tool
um for for quick data retrieval
um these are things that are just
broadly useful across like anything that
you want to build and and I think that
some of the
language models now have that feel as
well as some of the other things that
we're building like the translation tool
that that you just referenced so text to
speech and speech to text you've
expanded it from around 100 languages to
more than 1100 languages yeah and you
can identify more than the model can
identify more than
4 000 spoken languages which is 40 times
more than any known previous technology
to me that's really really exciting in
terms of connecting the world breaking
down barriers that language creates yeah
I think being able to translate between
all of these different
pieces in real time this has been a
kind of common sci-fi idea that we'd all
have you know whether it's
on an earbud or glasses or something
that can help translate in real time
um between all these different languages
and that's one that I think technology
is basically delivering now so I think
yeah I think that's pretty pretty
exciting uh you mentioned the next
version of llama what can you say about
the next version of llama what what can
you say about like what uh what were you
working on in terms of release in terms
of the vision for that well a lot of
what we're doing is taking the first
version which was primarily you know
this research version and trying to now
build a version
that has
all of the latest state-of-the-art
safety precautions built in
um and and we're
um we're using some more data to train
it from across our services but
but a lot of the the work that we're
doing internally is really just focused
on making sure that this is
um you know as
aligned and responsible as possible and
you know we're building a lot of our own
you know we're talking about kind of the
open source infrastructure but you know
the
the main thing that we focus on building
here you know a lot of product
experiences to help people connect and
express themselves so yeah we're gonna
I've talked about a bunch of this stuff
but um and you'll have an assistant that
you can talk to in WhatsApp
um you know I think I I think in the
future every Creator will will have kind
of an AI agent that can kind of act on
their behalf that their fans can talk to
I I want to get to the point where every
small business basically has an AI agent
that people can talk to for you know to
do Commerce and customer support and
things like that so they're going to be
all these different things and
llama or the language model underlying
this is is basically going to be the
engine that powers that the reason to
open source it is that um as as we did
with um with the the first version is
that it uh
basically it unlocks a lot of innovation
in the ecosystem will make our products
better as well and also gives us a lot
of valuable feedback on security and
safety which is important for making
this good but yeah I mean the the work
that we're doing to advance the
infrastructure it's um it's basically at
this point taking it Beyond a research
project into something which is ready to
be kind of core infrastructure not only
for our own products but
um you know hopefully for for a lot of
other things out there too do you think
the Llama Or the language model
underlying that version two will be open
sourced
you're you have internal debate around
that the pros and cons and so on this is
I mean we were talking about the debates
that we have internally and I think
um
I think the question is how to do it
right I mean it's I think we
you know we did the research license for
V1 and and I think the the big thing
that we're that we're thinking about is
is basically like what's the what's the
right the right way so there was a leak
that happened I don't know if you can
comment on it for V1 you know we
released it as a research project
um for researchers to be able to use but
in doing so we put it out there so
um you know we were very clear that
anyone who uses the the code and the
weights doesn't have a commercial
license to put into products and we've
we've generally seen people respect that
right it's like you don't have any
reputable companies that are basically
trying to put this into into
um their commercial products but but
yeah but by sharing it with you know so
many researchers it's it's you know yeah
it did leave the building but uh what
have you learned from that process that
you might be able to apply to V2 about
how to release it safely effectively uh
if if you release it yeah well I mean I
think a lot of the feedback like I said
is just around you know different things
around you know how do you fine-tune
models to make them more aligned and
safer and you see all the different data
recipes that
um you mentioned a lot of different
projects that are based on this I mean
there's one at Berkeley there's you know
it's just like all over and um
and
people have tried a lot of different
things and we've tried a bunch of stuff
internally so kind of where we're we're
making progress
here but also we're able to learn from
some of the best ideas in the community
and you know I think it you know we want
to just continue continue pushing that
forward but I don't have any news to
announce um if that's if that's what
you're you're asking I mean this is a a
thing that
we're uh
we're still we're still kind of you know
actively working through the the right
way to move forward here the details of
the secret sauce are still being
developed I see uh can you comment on
what do you think of uh the thing that
worked for gbt which is the
reinforcement learning with human
feedback so doing this alignment process
do you find it interesting and as part
of that let me ask because I talked to
Jan lacun before talking to you today he
asked me to ask or suggested that I ask
do you think
llm fine tuning will need to be
crowdsourced Wikipedia Style
so crowdsourcing
so this kind of idea of how to integrate
the human in the fine tuning of these
Foundation models yeah I think that's a
really interesting idea that I've talked
to Jan about a bunch
um
and
we were talking about
how do you basically train these models
to be as as safe and aligned and
responsible as possible and you know
different groups out there who are doing
development test different data recipes
in fine tuning but this idea that you
you just mentioned is
that at the end of the day
instead of having kind of one group
fine-tune some stuff and another group
you know produce a different fine-tuning
recipe and then
us trying to figure out which one we
think works best to produce the most
aligned model
um
I I do think that
it would be nice if you could get to a
point where you had a Wikipedia style
collaborative
way for a kind of a broader Community to
um to fine-tune it as well now there's a
lot of challenges in that both from an
infrastructure and like uh Community
Management and product perspective about
how you do that so I I haven't worked
that out yet
um but as an idea I think it's it's
quite compelling and I think it it goes
well with the ethos of open sourcing the
technology is also finding a way to have
a kind of Community Driven
um a Community Driven training of it
um but I think there are a lot of
questions on this in general these this
these questions around what's the the
best way to produce aligned AI models
it's very much a research area and it's
one that I think we will need to make as
much progress on as the kind of core
intelligence capability of the of the um
the models themselves well I just did a
conversation with Jimmy Wales the
founder of Wikipedia and to me Wikipedia
is one of the greatest websites ever
created
and it's a kind of a miracle that it
works and I think it has to do with
something that you mentioned which is
community you have a small community of
editors
that somehow work together well and they
uh they handle very controversial
topics and they handle it
would balance and with Grace despite
sort of the attacks that will often
happen a lot of the time I mean it's not
it's it has issues just like any other
human system but yes I mean the balance
is I mean it's a it's amazing what
they've been able to achieve but it's
also not perfect and I think that that's
um there's still a lot of challenges
right it's uh the more controversial the
topic the more the more difficult uh the
uh
the journey towards quote-unquote truth
or knowledge or wisdom that Wikipedia
tries to capture in the same way AI
models will need to
be able to generate those same things
truth knowledge and wisdom and how do
you align those models that they
generate
um something that uh is closest to truth
there's these concerns about
misinformation all this kind of stuff
that nobody can Define
and it's a it's something that we
together as a human species have to
Define like what is truth and how to
help AI systems generate that one of the
things language models do really well is
generate convincing sounding things that
can be completely wrong
and so how do you align it
uh to be less wrong
and part of that is the training and
part of that is the alignment and
however you do the alignment stage and
just like you said it's a very new and a
very open research problem
yeah and I think there's also
a lot of questions about whether the
current architecture for llms
as you continue scaling it what happens
um I mean a lot of the a lot of what's
been exciting in the last year
is that there's there's clearly a
qualitative breakthrough where you know
with with some of the GPT models
um that opened I put out and and that
others have been able to do as well
I I think it reached a kind of level of
quality where people like wow this is
this feels different and
um
and like it's going to be able to be the
foundation for building a lot of awesome
products and experiences and value but I
think the other realization that people
have is wow we just made a breakthrough
um
if there are other breakthroughs quickly
then I think that there's the sense that
maybe where we're closer to general
intelligence but I think that that idea
is predicated on the idea that I I think
people believe that there's still
generally a bunch of additional
breakthroughs to make and that it's um
we just don't know
how long it's going to take to get there
and in one view that some people have
um this doesn't tend to be my view as
much is that simply
scaling the current llms and you know
getting to higher parameter count models
by itself we'll we'll get to something
that is closer to
um to to general intelligence but
um I don't know I tend to think that
there's probably more more um
if fundamental steps that need to be
taken along the way there but still the
leaves taken
with this extra alignment step is quite
incredible quite surprising to to a lot
of folks and on top of that
when you start to have hundreds of
millions of people potentially using a
product that integrates that
you can start to see civilization
transforming effects before you achieve
super quote-unquote super intelligence
it could be super transformative without
being a super intelligence oh yeah I
mean I think that they're going to be a
lot of amazing products and value that
can be created with the current level of
Technology
um
to some degree
yeah I'm excited to
work on a lot of those products over the
next few years and I think it would just
create
a tremendous amount of whiplash if the
number of breakthroughs keeps like if if
they're keep on being stacked
breakthroughs because I think to some
degree industry in the world needs some
time to kind of build these
breakthroughs into the products and
experiences that we all use so we can
actually benefit from them
um
but
I don't know I think there's just a a
like an awesome amount of stuff to do
and I think about like all of the
I don't know small businesses or
individual entrepreneurs out there who
um you know now we're going to be able
to you know get help coding the things
that they need to go build things or
designing the things that they need or
um we'll be able to you know use these
models to be able to do customer support
for the people that they're that they're
serving you know over WhatsApp without
having to you know I I think that that's
that's just gonna be I I just think that
this is all going to be yeah super
exciting it's going to create better
better experiences for people and just
unlock a ton of innovation and value